all right so thank you all for coming
it's a pleasure to be up here in front
of you today to be able to talk about
building hybrid rust and c-sharp apps
without sacrificing safety or too much
sanity there's a little sanity loss but
I promise it's not too much our first a
little bit about me my name is ash you
can find me around on github and Twitter
and various other channels under the
code Arras handle part of the rust lips
team and an engineer at data lust where
we work on a Diagnostics platform called
seek so we're going to be looking at
running rust in c-sharp together in a
single application I'm not going to try
and convince you today that this is
actually something that you're going to
want to do because while C sharp and
rust or independently memory safe
languages the only way we can stitch
them together is by pretending that
they're C and so that means throwing out
all the safety that we're used to
working within them and having to
rebuild that ourselves and doing that
requires a fairly deep understanding of
both the doughnut runtime and the rust
language what I am going to try and do
is use the process of having to
explicitly work with language and
runtime features that are normally at
work for us implicitly to offer a fresh
perspective on these languages so if
you've mostly been working in safe
c-sharp for a long time then there are
aspects of the c-sharp language and the
dotnet runtime that you might not have
actually come across before
even though those will be at work
somewhere in the stack that you're
working with and so having a look at
those explicitly may give us a fresh
appreciation for this workhorse
languages that we use every day and the
kinds of things that somebody has had to
do in order to make the code that we
write safe
similarly for rusty if you've had a look
at the language in the past we've tried
to pick it up and couldn't quite get why
the language is designed the way it is
what it's actually trying to achieve why
various features work the way that they
do are then seeing them at work for us
today in the real world context of
rebuilding safety in a hybrid app may
help us build additional context and a
deeper understanding of this language so
that we can feel more productive when we
use it so I'm not going to be assuming
too much familiarity of rust coming into
this but we're going to be looking at
weird and unsafe
for the most part so we're not gonna
spend a lot of time fussing on syntax
we're going to be focusing on concepts
how those broader concepts map to
language features and how how those
language features help us build safety
so this is going to be less a gentle
introduction to rust and Maura firehose
of rust right to the face but we should
be able to follow along just fine okay
so let's start with a little bit of
background so I mentioned I work on a
Diagnostics platform called seek this is
seek it's really a database you send a
diagnostic data in the form of buckets
of structured logs sequel and organize
those on disk for you and allow you to
query them back using its sequel like
query language so seek is a database
that is specialized to a very particular
workload and that's ordered range
queries over semi structured time series
data that's really what seek is at the
side of 2018 C equals a Windows product
built on the full dotnet framework and
c-sharp with some fairly deep ties to
the Windows platform over the course of
that year we broke that dependency on
Windows and we shipped a new version of
the seek product with support for Linux
and Windows based on that core so six
dependency on Windows went right to the
heart of the data base in the heart of a
database is its storage engine so seek
would be organizing its data on disk
using Assent your centers this database
suite that's baked into Windows it's
used by various windows features and so
we would have our high-level events or
organizing data into seven day blocks
each block would be in each sent
database so we had to break that
dependency but it wasn't just a matter
of breaking our dependency on his hat in
order to move to cross-platform
one of the issues with you sent is that
as like a disk backed b-tree it wasn't
really ideal for seeks workload of semi
structured data so rather than just
replacing his sent with some equivalent
cross-platform solution and accepting
exactly the same trade-offs that we
already had we thought it would be
better to lower in storage engine
because why not you know copy our HUD so
that's what we did we built a storage
engine and we built it in rust so now we
have a c-sharp database
and a rust storage engine and we can see
now that we get visibility all the way
from the high level c-sharp events store
right through to the individual rust
components in the storage engine and
then down to actual files on disk so
what we're looking at here is a hybrid
app but what is a hybrid app in the
general sense we can think of a hybrid
app as many languages many run times and
many paradigms all bundled up together
in a single f5 experience so to give you
an idea of what I mean if you're mostly
working on line of business applications
and dotnet then you might be familiar
with this kind of stack you have
something like a c-sharp server a
JavaScript or a typescript client and
the two are connected via HTTP API
oftentimes the JavaScript client is the
only consumer of your c-sharp server so
they're logically one system that a
coupled via an API and they present a
single experience at the end-user
but there's separate runtimes the kind
of hybrid app we're going to be talking
about today is having c-sharp code and
russ code coexisting within the same
actual process and rather than
communicating via HTTP api they
communicate via shared application
binary interface that allows the dot
near runtime to call russ functions so
why would we actually want to do this it
kind of sounds like a lot of work
already so why would we take our
existing c-sharp database and then throw
rust into it why didn't we build our
storage engine in c-sharp or
alternatively why didn't we go the big
bang rewrite it in rust path throw out
all of our existing code and try and
build a new seek from scratch and rust
the answer for us comes down to language
trade-offs fundamentally all languages
are designed with trade-offs in mind
there are no free lunches so there is no
universally perfect language as much as
we might like to think there is and so
seek is a fairly large product has
different requirements for different
components our storage engine sets the
low-water mark for our performance
characteristics and it sets the
high-water mark for our safety so what
we need is for the runtime performance
impact of our storage engine to be as
low as possible so we have as
much room to move as we can for
high-level features on top and we can't
build a database on top of our storage
engine that's any safer than a storage
engine itself is because while
reliability doesn't guarantee safety if
we have a none and unsafe or unreliable
storage engine then it's going to be
very hard to build a safe database on
top of it and rust is really geared to
that kind of code that's safety and
performance critical code but not all of
siik is like that we also have higher
level features we have domain entities
we have migrations we have components
that need to interact and deal with
versioning over time we have a Web API
and all of that stuff is bread and
butter for c-sharp because it's a very
concise and productive language with
great dev time tooling and it has a lot
of mature libraries like it or not
though it's not just a case of being
able to pick and choose languages that
you want from the language tree take the
things that you like out of those and
ignore the constraints because there are
no free lunches we can't build a hybrid
app without accepting new trade-offs
there's real complexity in stitching two
language runtimes together
but what's important is how this
complexity manifests itself throughout
our system so what we end up with is
localized concentrated complexity in the
stitching layer that doesn't need to
permeate through the rest of the code
bases so what we end up with in seek is
this very large safe idiomatic c-sharp
code base a large safe idiomatic rust
code base and then this thin slice of
insanity in the middle and it's that
thin slice I've been saying they were
going to be looking at today
so why rust I've kind of implied up to
this point that rust has something to
offer us from building a storage engine
that we felt made it more appropriate
than c-sharp so I mentioned that our
storage engine sets the low-water mark
for our performance characteristics in
order to build high-performance c-sharp
code we need to limit GC work limiting
GC work means relying on value types as
a bit of a thought exercise let's
pretend the c-sharp I only have value
types
so exactly c-sharp but no classes if you
try to build a system in this language
what kinds of limitations would you
expect to hit if you've tried to build
code based on strikes you can probably
think of a few already the answer though
is fewer limitations in c-sharp today
than in the c-sharp of yesterday say
between c-sharp 5 and c-sharp 8 with the
introduction of ref strikes disposable
ref strikes ref read-only fields ref
locals reference all of these things
make value types more capable and make
working with some more ergonomic if you
keep following that path along into the
future you might end up with a language
that looks like rust
we'll see sharp 15 have a bar checker
you know it's so we can really think of
rust as dotnet value types with special
superpowers because rust is
fundamentally data types of
fundamentally value types it makes them
nice to work with so anything that you
wish you could do with value types in
c-sharp but felt like you couldn't you
probably can't do in rust what that
means is that when we're writing rust we
get the benefits of writing with value
types we get a stable runtime with low
overhead we have zero cost abstractions
because things are stack based when
you're writing performance sensitive
rust code you can use closures you can
use iterators which are rust version of
link so we don't have to work in a
subset of the language and compound the
inherent complexity of building a
storage engine with the complexity of
knowing what features of the language
were allowed to use rust also has a
strong safety culture so there's a lot
of knowledge sharing about what kinds of
unsafe code or ok to write and what kind
aren't and why and that's important when
you're writing this kind of code as well
alright so let's actually take a look at
this lat rust language and we're going
to do that with some c-sharp equivalents
the goal isn't really to do our rust
versity Sharpe kind of thing there's not
very useful
the idea is assuming that you're more
familiar with c-sharp we can build some
context around how rust approaches the
same kinds of problems all right so
let's have a look at some strokes so in
c-sharp we declare a value type as a
structure can have fields in rust we
declare a value type as a struct and you
can have fields so far they're fairly
similar but there is one difference
already and that's that little derive
annotation in rust that hash derive is
an attribute and like attributes in
dotnet they allow us to annotate our
items with additional semantics in this
case that derive
makes the semantics of our russet struct
equivalent to the dotnet struct
so in dotnet all value types have a
initial default value value that you can
initialize them to even if that default
doesn't make semantic sense flat struct
in rust we have to opt into that by
deriving default in dotnet we say that
value types have copy semantics when you
pass a value type by value into a method
a copy of that value is made and that's
what you work with a method when the
method runs out you can add a scope
there any changes you made to that
struct will be lost in rust we say that
strikes have moved semantics by default
so when you pass a value type by value
into a method a copy is still made but
the original is invalidated and the one
true version of that instance is passed
into that method when it goes out of
scope then rust will destroy it we can
opt in to copy semantics in rust though
by deriving clone and copy so we see
immediately some differences between how
value types behave by default and rust
in c-sharp but we don't just declare
values and pass them around by value we
share them so ignoring object references
which are overwhelmingly the most common
way that we share data in c-sharp
what does dotnet give us to share value
types it gives us managed pointers which
are a feature that you might not have
actually looked at directly because
c-sharp doesn't expose them directly
that's that little T and in the left
hand side there that is a managed
pointer it is a stack-based GC aware
reference to some data that may be on
the stack on the managed heap or it may
be unmanaged altogether
so while c-sharp doesn't expose them
directly it has a bunch of features that
use them ref parameters are like a
shared mutable reference and we have a
recent addition in T which is a shared
mutable reference ref lockerz ref
returns and ref fields those are all
based on manage pointers they allow us
to share data in a memory safe way rust
has its own safe way of sharing value
types and those are references so we
talked about the own T move semantics
rust has shared immutable references and
it has exclusive mutable references and
so the rules in rust are you may have a
bunch of shared immutable references or
you may have
single exclusive mutable one and you can
only mutate data through a mutable
reference so we also see that rust
references don't just track mutability
they also track lifetimes if you're
familiar with f-sharp
you might recognize that TK which is a
lifetime as a generic type parameter
it's not really a coincidence because
lifetimes in rust are types the types
that tell us the points in our program
for which that reference is valid and
can be used we track that lifetime
explicitly through the type of the
reference what does that actually give
us though so as an example to see what
explicit lifetime tracking buys us let's
have a look at value types that borrowed
data in c-sharp if we want a value type
that contains a manager two pointer
internally we declare it as a ref struct
we can then give it a span of bytes
which is borrowing from somewhere else
in rust an equivalent struct looks like
the one on the right we have a borrowed
type it takes a lifetime which we've
called kick ref as a generic type
parameter and we can then use that
lifetime for references in its fields so
that and you eight there is a slice it's
pretty much the same thing as a span of
bytes and so in rust we say that a
struct inherits the lifetime of its
fields so because borrowed has a
lifetime tik ref the borrowed struct
itself can't outlive that lifetime
otherwise we're pointing to invalid data
so we say that borrowed leaves fatigue
ref managed pointers in dotnet manage
their lifetime heuristic ly by being
bound to the stack you can't box a
managed pointer because it may point to
stack data and then you would invalidate
it because in dotnet when we box a value
we talk about promoting it to the
managed heap we change the semantics of
its lifetime when we box a value the GC
takes ownership of it and it won't
reclaim that value until it's no longer
reachable so we say it has an
arbitrarily long lifetime whereas on the
stack it has an arbitrarily short one so
it's not valid for us to box borrowed
structs in c-sharp as a consequence of
that we can't use borrowed value types
as Gennaro
type parameters because in dotnet we
assume that it's valid to box a generic
rust doesn't have that same restriction
it's totally okay for you to box
bio-data in rust because rusts heat
doesn't add semantics it's just an
allocation space our allocation there
won't outlive the borrow of some slice
that we pass in it's a bit of a
pointless box but you can still do it we
also have no problem passing borrowed
data in rust as generic type parameters
because the lifetime becomes part of the
type rather than assuming saying net
where it's valid for us to extend the
lifetime of a generic type in rust we
assume that that T value is only valid
for the block although the scope of
takes generic so we have restrictive
default type constraints rather than
permissive ones so that's a whole lot of
words but what does it really mean so to
give you an example of what these things
that we've just talked about get us when
writing real code let's have a look at
some bad code that I wrote so this is a
method in c-sharp it has a bug in it
it's not even a very long method and I
still managed to screw it up by adding
my defense I didn't actually write it
broken to begin with I refactored it
broken which I don't know I guess I
makes it a little better if you're
looking for the bug just follow the
sunglasses then the problem there is we
rent a buffer from our memory pool and
we need to dispose it to return it so we
make a using statement in there and we
then logically move ownership of that
rented buffer into our data that we
returned but before we return our data
we're going to return the buffer to the
pool if we do sugar that code we can see
it a bit more clearly we create our data
that we're going to return disposed the
buffer and then return the result
somebody else is going to rent that
buffer we're both going to be slapping
bytes into it at the same time and we
have a data race and that's a bad time
the problem here is that we see Sharpe
is relying on us to be good programmers
which I am at least not so I end up
writing bugs like this and have a bad
time if I translate this code directly
into rust it actually looks very similar
because my see
Karp is kind of rusty it looks pretty
much the same but there's one difference
and the difference is that we don't have
the same bug because rust tracks
ownership explicitly it knows that when
we pass ownership of our rented buffer
into the data that we return it
shouldn't return it to the pool until
data goes out of scope and that's move
semantics at work for us the compiler
generates the right code rather than
relying on us to do it what if we try
and dietra our rust the same way as the
c-sharp though in this case we get a
compile error and the problem here is
move semantics at work again for us rust
knows that we moved our buffer into
Darla's it's not valid for us to try and
drop it so drop is kind of similar to
dispose in rust so we get a compile
error instead of a data race up till now
though it might feel like I've been
picking on c-sharp a bit that's not what
I mean to do there's a reason that seek
is predominantly written in c-sharp and
that's because it gives us a lot - and
one thing that we can't overstate is the
maturity of its ecosystem so we get asp
net core which is this vast capable
mature web framework that's suitable not
only for our high-throughput ingestion
needs but also our more standard web api
calls the power of the UI and there just
isn't that same level of maturity and
rust web frameworks yet cuz Aspen has
been going for like 15 or years or
something we also get mature projects in
the ecosystem like stereo for logging
and auto fact for IRC I think Auto fact
deserves its own slide because it
captures pattern that allows us to scale
c-sharp code bases really effectively so
what we're looking at here is auto FAQ
at work not just mapping abstractions to
implementations which is the least
interesting thing that noisy container
will do for you but it describes
relationships between the components in
our system and how those come together
so in this case we collect all of our
server tasks at runtime along with some
metadata about how to schedule them
except for our metrics tasks which we
deal with explicitly and without
reflection you just kind of can't write
the same code in rust you have to know
everything up front
something else that we get from C sharp
is the compile time the dev time tooling
so as an example our C sharp set code
base is about twice the size of our
rusty code base compiling C sharp
compiling our seek project in a fresh
debug build takes about three seconds
for our Rosco base it takes about two
minutes and the reason they're different
is that in C sharp we compile ahead of
time to an intermediate language and
then get it at run time into machine
code whereas in rust we compile ahead of
time using an optimizing compiler LLVM
straight into machine code so this is
really an apples to oranges comparison
but that's also kind of the point
because sometimes you want apples and
sometimes you want oranges all right so
we've had a look at what a hybrid app is
why we might want to build one why we
decided to build one and what we think
rust and c-sharp each bring to the table
so now let's have a little look at how
we go about stitching them together in a
single application so to do that what
I've done is I've wasted now FF I
infrastructure out of seek our friend up
on github with a sample c-sharp API on
one side and a sample rust database
based on a project called sled on the
other side which you should also check
out and and I'll put that up so that we
can have a look at how we go about doing
this it's permissively licensed so you
can pill for it to your heart's content
this is what it looks like so it is a
fairly extensive example it covers a
whole lot of things that we can't cover
directly today like how to integrate
cargo with msbuild how to debug dotnet
code using lldp all that kind of stuff
so I encourage you to check it out if
you're interested in exploring this
stuff further so it includes a c-sharp
Web API and a rust database and this
user interface which deserves no further
discussion this is not sick this is my
amazing playing around with angular but
what it allows us to do is create a
document in your database and we're
going to have a quick tour of how our
hybrid app works by creating a document
so we'll say hello Oslo and it's called
here even though it's
I don't know if anyone else's - brush
will have exactly the same temperature
in Australia at the moment even though
we're in the middle of winter and we get
you guys get like 18 hours of Sun limit
since then so when we set that okay so
here we are in our sample app we're on
the C sharp Web API at the moment so
what we've done is we've posted a JSON
document to this endpoint we're going to
collect that up with its key and we're
going to write that to a database so
what we do is we read into an eye memory
owner this is a new API in c-sharp it
represents some owned piece of dumb
memory that we're responsible for
reclaiming so we transfer ownership of
the memory into our data struct now we
need to begin a write transaction so to
do that we call into rust
so this bindings dot DB write begin here
this is a rust function and it's going
to return a write transaction for us to
use so here we are now we're in rust in
order to begin our write transaction we
allocate a handle in rust heap
allocating that handle means calling
into our idiomatic rust database which
in this case is fairly simple we just
create a clone of it so once we've
allocated our handle we return okay now
we have a write transaction we can begin
we can actually set our document so to
do that we copy the data key into a
stack local in this example database our
keys are a fixed to 16 byte value
because it's on the stack it's OK for us
to take a pointer to it we get a fixed
pointer to the value which we can see
has the content and now we're going to
call in our rust function so back on the
rust side we rematerializing a view of
the data based on the inputs that we got
from c-sharp and we set it in our
database that's not very interesting so
I'll just skip over that we return ok so
now that we've set our document we
dispose our write transaction and that
means calling spose because we had it in
a using block calling back into rust we
call complete that flushes the bytes
that we just wrote to disk
we then complete our action and now we
have a document saved in our database so
that's a quick view of this sample app
that we're going to be looking at and I
cannot I cannot into gestures so there
are a few pieces in there we have a
c-sharp API we have some c-sharp
bindings we have some rough bindings and
we have a rust database so the first
thing we're going to look at are the
bindings the c-sharp and the rough slide
and these are the fundamental way that
we stitch these two languages together
there are effectively C functions what
we do is we declare them and implement
them in rust and we then import and call
them in c-sharp what's important is that
various parts and aspects of these
functions line up they need to have the
same calling convention so we know who's
responsible for cleaning up the stack
they need to have the same name so that
M in c-sharp we can find them that's
what that little no mangle attribute
does it stops us from messing with the
name of the function that we export in
they need to have the same arguments and
those arguments need to have the same
ABI that means they need to have the
same representation in c-sharp as they
do in rust so what actually happens when
we execute a rust function in c-sharp
we don't just call it directly there's a
feature of the.net runtime called P
invoke that comes into play here and
what P invoke does is when the runtime
encounters an unmanaged call it
generates a whole lot of code around it
to make sure that that unmanaged code
integrates into the dollar at runtime
correctly so believe it or not your
c-sharp code that you write that is
executing in the.net runtime has a
specific ABI that it has to conform to
because the dotnet runtime needs to be
able to work with that managed code in
order to do GC reporting dotnet will
walk all of your manage stack frames and
try and find GC roots in specific
locations so that it can report them to
the garbage collector we can't guarantee
that unmanaged code is going to report
it stack frames correctly similarly
manage our threads that are running
managed code need to cooperate in the
runtime to decide when it
see could actually occur once again our
managed code isn't necessarily going to
do that so what we do is before our
unmanaged code we tell a runtime that
we're going to enter an unmanaged
context it knows to skip all those
unmanaged frames when it does a stack
walk it knows not to block on that
thread if it needs to do what you see
and when we return then the doughnut
runtime will check whether a GC using
progress and make sure that it waits
appropriately for it so the P invoke is
that little il stub P invoke there we
don't actually write that that is
generated for us by the dotnet runtime
and that's also a place for special
marshalling to occur for arguments that
need to be converted into an ABI
compatible representation so below that
P invoke we have our C sharp stack trace
and above that P invoke we have our
rough stack trace for the function that
we actually called so P invoke
introduces costs on executing unmanaged
code you're probably not going to be
able to build a hybrid app with
piecemeal functions written in rust if
you think it's going to make your code
faster the reason is that the cost of
the PM VOC may well just do off the cost
of the unmanaged function call and then
you've just wasted your time
in our case pretty much every unmanaged
function call means pulling data from
disk or writing it to disk so that's
gonna oblivia the cost of pretty well
anything that we can do on either end so
right now we have bindings diff
effectively C functions we have no
safety around them in order to rebuild
safety in these bindings we use some
special types on the rough side because
rust is really nice for modeling safety
contracts that's the place where we
rebuild our safety so there's a couple
here that we're gonna look up there's
this ref type there's an out type let's
handle share thing and a DB result so
let's have a look at the DB result first
DB result is about error management
internet our mechanism for error
management exceptions methods can throw
exceptions we can catch them refrozen we
have finally blocks where we can execute
code regardless of exceptions that's how
we do it and on there in rust error
management is done through result we
declare a method as fallible explicit
léa by making it return a result which
may be one variant okay in this case
unit will void or some error we can't
get at the okay result we've got
exhaustively matching on the on the
result that we get in handling the
potential error case the overwhelmingly
most common thing that you're going to
want to do if you get an error in rust
you simply punt it upstream for somebody
else to do with and that's what that
little question mark operator does when
we were in the body of a fallible method
we can call other fallible methods we
can use the question mark to early
return with an error and at that point
we know if we're continuing then it's
okay so we can use the okay variant and
that's how here error management and
rust so what we really want is to use
the idiomatic error management strategy
in either language we want to be able to
return errors with Rask using question
mark and we want those errors to throw
as exceptions in c-sharp that we might
want to catch doing that demonstrates a
problem with our FFR though and that is
that we're restricted in the kinds of
data that we can send to and from the
boundary rusts result is as percent a
special kind of enum that doesn't have a
representation in dotnet even though I'm
sure you'd all really like there to be
one so we can't just send the rest
result over the FFI boundary we have to
declare our own and so that's what we do
that's what DB result is that Reaper see
there is an attribute that says lay this
thing out the same way that C would so
that we have a common ABI that we can
use on c-sharp
so DB result has a kind which is a
32-bit value it can be okay or an
internal error or a couple of other
variants depending on and what's going
on it also has a 32-bit ID so in totally
our DB result is a 64-bit value that we
return from our FFA on its own though
that DB result doesn't actually give us
a lot of information if we get an
internal error that doesn't really tell
us why we got one or what we can
actually do about it so in order to send
diagnostic information across the FFI
boundary we do the same thing that
Windows does which is when an error
occurs we set some more diagnostic
information in the last result a thread
local buffer if we get an error in
c-sharp it could then read
contents of their buffer and format them
into an exception message so that's what
this last result is all about what that
means is now in our binding function we
can use the question mark operator which
we hook into so if we're returning a DB
result and we question mark we
automatically format that error into our
thread local buffer and return with DB
result internal error on the c-sharp
side we have an equivalent
implementation of DB result it has a
kind and an ID it has a struct layout of
sequential so it's laid out the same way
that the rust one is and when we
encounter DB result we check it if it's
okay we just return otherwise we get the
contents of that thread local buffer and
we check the IDS match that's why it has
an ID on it because if we don't check in
between an error then we won't we might
end up formatting the wrong error
message into our exception and things
will just get even more confusing so
that's what DB result is all about it's
about error management and then let's
have a look at ref so ref is about how
we share data from c-sharp across the
boundary to rust
so rust doesn't understand nets manage
pointers which we talked about before
and c-sharp doesn't understand rusts
references so in order to share data
across the boundary we use unmanaged
pointers and on net we have this T star
variant which is typed and we have the
untyped int pointer variant there are
some subtleties with unmanaged pointers
though because as they are so named they
are unmanaged whereas with manage
pointers they integrate with the GC in
two interesting ways the first is that
manage pointers participate in
determining the liveness of the point e
so when we're checking whether or not
our value is reachable if we can reach
it through a managed pointer we know
that it is secondly when the GC performs
the collection it may move objects
around in order to prevent fragmentation
that means the actual address of a value
can change basically between any two
statements when that does happen we will
update manage pointers automatically so
you don't even need to know
unmanaged pointers don't participate in
any of that and if you end up running
afoul of either of those things then you
create what's called a GC halt so in
order to get the unmanaged address of
some managed data we have to be in an
unsafe context and we use this fixed
statement it means that within the body
of that fixed statement we won't collect
the value that we've got the address of
and we won't move it if a collection
occurs so that pointer is only valid for
the scope of that fixed block once we
have one we can pass it to our FF I rust
has its own version of unmanaged
pointers
they're just rule pointers we have the
star quantity version and we have a star
mutti version
besides variants over t where star
quantity is variant in star mutti is
invariant they're more or less the same
thing you can freely coerce for a star
constant to a star mute what they give
us is documentation as type style thing
where you treat a star constants so you
shouldn't mutate it and if you have a
star mute then you probably own it or at
least have an exclusive reference so you
can mutate it raw pointers in rust have
their own weird interactions with the
safe memory management system in this
case we can convert a raw pointer into a
safe reference but there is a subtlety
and that is in that lifetime so we call
that lifetime tick unbounded because
that's what it is typically in rust when
you borrow data you borrow it based on a
borrow of something on the input in this
case we don't have that so that lifetime
is kind of hallucination it comes out of
nowhere and what or us will do if it
encounters one of those is it will just
use any lifetime that makes the code
compile so it's actually not a useful
lifetime at all we could accidentally
extend that value and use it after it's
valid which would be a really bad time
so the ref type is here to fix that it
has a Reaper of transparent which in
rust means that it has the same ABI as
it's one sized field so in this case
when we receive a real pointer we simply
interpret it as a ref and we get safety
there's no there's no other changes to
the way that we passed the type that are
needed we see that ref has a life
tick fixed we call that lifetime tick
fixed because that represents the
lifetime of the fixed block from which
that real pointer was acquired and if we
remember from before we say that strikes
in Rusk have a lifetime bound to the
lifetimes of their fields then we say
that Ref can't outlive that fixed block
from C sharp for which the real pointer
is valid
similarly rather than returning a
reference from our Ref that has an
unbounded lifetime we bind it to a
borrow of the ref and if we remember the
borrow the ref itself is only valid for
the fixed block so the borrow of the
data we get out of it can only be valid
for the fixed block and so that prevents
us from being able to borrow data that
would outlive the point from which that
data is actually valid then we go from C
sharp so that's ref ref is about sharing
readable data from dotnet into rust now
let's have a look at out so after is
about writer and the arguments or out
parameters in c-sharp we have our
parameters we usually use them because
we wish we had enums but we don't so we
use our parameters but they're fairly
interesting in their own right because
we're expected to initialize an out
parameter as an optimization they may be
pointing to uninitialized memory to
begin with because we can't read it
without initializing it Russ doesn't
actually have a concept of out
explicitly at least not yet so we
declare our own out pointer it looks
fairly similar to ref it has that same
tick fixed lifetime which once again
represents a fixed block in c-sharp but
it's a little different because
uninitialized memory in rust is rather
weird and tricky compared to
uninitialized memory in net which is
actually fairly hard to get ahold of so
in rust there is a lot of undefined
behavior to be found by creating
references to uninitialized data
it's especially undefined behavior to
dereference uninitialized data but russ
may be doing that without you knowing
him so for instance if we simply write a
value bar through an exclusive reference
into an uninitialized value rust will
move out of what was already there which
is not valid because it was garbage
so for any arbitrary value the only
valid way to initialize it and rust is
by using this pointer right method it's
quite subtle so we create this out type
to encapsulate that so we don't
accidentally dereference uninitialized
memory and do something really weird
there's one exception though that's
fairly significant and that's this reed
trait so in rusts we can think of reed
as like the reed side of streams in
dotnet they allow us to pass a mutable
byte buffer that data will be read into
and we can then use that we really want
to be able to pass an uninitialized byte
buffer into this though because we don't
want to have to initialize this enormous
buffer full of zeros only to immediately
initialize it with some other values
right away so this guy has to be defined
behavior even though there are some
people in Ross community who would
really like it not to be so what we say
is that when an out parameter is
pointing just two raw bytes we have
additional things that we can do with
them that we're sure are going to be ok
we can get an exclusive reference to
that uninitialized memory if we pinky
promise that we're not going to read it
we can also initialize it with a slice
of bytes because there's no drop
semantics associated with those bytes
we're not going to create two copies of
the same thing so that's what art is all
about referee out are about short-lived
references from c-sharp data that we
share in rust and now let's have a look
at this handle shared so it handles
really the meat and potatoes of how we
build safety in the FFI we've looked at
short-lived data so far handles are for
long live data data that is valid across
multiple MFI calls so we think of our
handles as a pair there's a c-sharp
component and a rust component to them
the c-sharp component manages ownership
of some resource that was allocated in
rust heap and the rust component manages
access to that resource so on the
c-sharp side we take ownership of the
rust value we make sure that it's
reclaimed using the tools that are
available to dotnet that is using
garbage collector we make sure that if
that resource is reclaimed it is only
reclaimed once but c-sharp doesn't
guarantee synchronization of access to
that resource so that's the
responsibility of rust
so the way that we declare our handles
in c-sharp to satisfy the contract is by
using safe handle this is a thing that's
been around Annette since like dawn
there too it's been out for a long time
it's a class that wraps up a untyped
handle pointer to a handle it gives us
some point to implement and how to know
whether or not the handle is valid and
it gives us some code to implement to
actually release the handle which will
mean calling some rust function to
deallocate it we can't deallocate rust
from c-sharp we have to call in to rust
to do it
what hand what safe handle gives us is
an implementation of dispose that
synchronizes the calling of that release
handle that we can call manually and it
gives us a finalizar
if you haven't worked with unmanaged
data in dotnet before you might not have
seen a finalizar
that's that little Tilda safe handle at
the bottom there finalizar is really a
way that we can plug code into the GC so
that we can run our own code when a
collection runs over our value and in
this case the finalizar make sure that
we call release handle so even if we
don't manually dispose it it will get
cleaned up for us safe handle inherits
from the sting called critical finalizer
object in.net as a general rule pretty
much anything that inherits from
critical something has some kind of
runtime semantics associated with it in
this case it makes sure that if we do
reach finalization then the finalizer
aver handle runs after everything else
just in case there are other objects we
collected that still need to access it
so there's a lot of subtlety around
cleaning up unmanaged resources and safe
handle takes care of those for us
there's actually another subtlety as
well around the synchronization of
Reclamation and that is safe handle make
sure that we can't reclaim an unmanaged
resource while there might be unmanaged
code using it and the way it does that
is through reference counting so
internally our safe handle as a
reference count because safe handle is
understood by the dotnet runtime in the
P and VOC stub that we generated earlier
it will generate code around our
unmanaged function to increment the ref
count before our unmanaged call and then
decrement it afterwards so that if we're
within DB read next here we can't
release the handle
it'll wait until we return so as an
example here's what one of our handles
looks like it's fairly simple and we
just say the handles invalid if it's
zero and calm releasing it call means
calling a rust function even if that
function fails we guarantee that we've D
allocated the resulting rust so return
true in previous versions of death net
there used to be a whole lot of other
fluffing around that you would have to
do with handles like around constrained
execution regions and Hum managed code
security those things don't exist in
dotnet core so this is pretty much what
we need to do we don't guarantee that
our handle will be reclaimed but neither
does rust so that's probably okay so
that's what the c-sharp panels do they
manage ownership the rest handles
perform the actual allocation
de-allocation and they ensure that
access is requested by c-sharp are free
from data races because c-sharp doesn't
guarantee data race freedom on its own
we have to do that on the rest side so
the way that we do that in rust is by
using two traits and those traits are
send in sync they both model part of
rust concurrency story that make sure at
compile time
that data is only used in ways that are
valid if you've written rust before you
might have encountered send and sync but
you might have only encountered them
because you didn't satisfy them and got
some weird compiler error that didn't
make a lot of sense
salmon sink are what are called auto
traits auto traits in rust are
automatically implemented for you based
on the contents of your type so you
don't need to manually implement these
unless you're doing something kind of
weird which is exactly what we're doing
so intuitively send and sync work like
this so send tells us whether or not
it's safe to transfer ownership of some
value to another thread so on the left
hand side we create some state and we
move ownership into another thread from
that move keyword that requires send
some types that aren't send include
unsynchronized ref counts like RC or
types that use thread local state that's
not actually going to make sense on the
other thread sink on the other hand
tells us whether or not it's safe to
concurrently access a value so on the
right hand side we don't reverse a ship
into the thread we send a reference and
we try and use it because both threads
may be accessing their value at the same
time we require sync
so some types that don't implement sync
by default of types that have
unsynchronized interior mutability which
we're going to have a look at so we can
think of send in sync they seem kind of
weird at the moment but we can think of
them as modeling roughs concurrency
story as relationships between its
fundamental reference types so send in
sync tell us something about own types
and references to them so what thing
tells us is that if an underlying value
is safe to access concurrently then a
shared reference to that value is safe
to send to other threads and this is
kind of the crux of how Rus guarantees
data race freedom because if we can't
send shared references to other threads
then we can't access a value
concurrently and we're going to see that
exclusive references behave basically
the same as owned values in this case so
we say that an exclusive reference to T
is sync if the T itself is sync you may
think that that actually gives us a
place to create a data race where we
might have a shared reference to an
exclusive reference so we can have
shared exclusive references passed
around rus doesn't work like that
an exclusive reference behind a shared
reference becomes immutable so we don't
have a data race there one of the subtle
ones is send so if an underlying value
is sent that doesn't tell us anything
about a shared reference because it's
not necessarily safe to access
concurrently but we require that an
underlying value ascends if we want to
send an exclusive reference to it to
another thread which may seem kind of
weird because we're not actually sending
the value we're sending a reference but
in rust it's impossible for us to move
out of an exclusive reference using
something like mem replace we can move
out of it and replace it with a new
value and that would only be valid to do
if the underlying value itself can be
sent or moved into the thread that has
the reference so that's what's and in
sync are all about if we think about
what we need or what contract were given
by don't net we can figure out what our
handles in rust with our values and rust
need to do to satisfy data race freedom
so in dotnet we don't guarantee
synchronization of values you can use
the lock statement but
can also just use it incorrectly which
is something we've done in the past so
we need sync we need to guarantee that
whatever c-sharp does because it will
try and access values concurrently that
it's safe for that to be done similarly
finalization is an interesting case
because even if we manually dispose a
value and it doesn't reach finalization
sometimes we might forget and it will
and dotnet will run that finalization
code on another thread so it will move
out of our own managed resource from a
different thread than the one that
allocated it and so to do that we need
send so our handles need sand and sync
and that leads us to two different
handle designs that achieve these bounds
in different ways so we'll look at
handles shared first it achieves send
and sink through interior mutability
what that means is that it's just a
simple pointer it relies on the
underlying value being send in sync it
doesn't add any semantics of its own
it's kind of what it looks like it looks
a bit like ref but there are some
impulse here because our handle shed is
semantically a shared reference we say
that our handle shared is send when I
shared reference to the underlying value
is in similarly for sync when our handle
shared satisfies these bounds then we
can get and a shared reference to the
underlying value so that's handle shed
handle exclusive is a bit different it
achieves send and sink through inherited
mutability it allows us to pull an
exclusive reference out of our handle
exclusive value without creating data
races so it looks kind of similar to
handle shared but there's a difference
it has this thread bound of thing in it
you might be able to guess what that's
about just from the name but we use it
to satisfy send in sync instead of the
underlying value so we say that our
candle exclusiva send when a thread
bound is sent and a handling squib is
sync when a thread bound to sink and
when they are we can get an exclusive
reference so how does that actually work
how are we able to get an exclusive
reference out of a handle that might be
shared from multiple threads the answer
is three thread band so thread bound is
this kind of weird type it allows us to
share values without creating data races
by binding them to the thread that
originally created them so it's only
possible to pull a reference out of our
thread bound from a thread that
originally allocated it doesäôt by using
a thread ID it stores the inner value in
an unsafe cell which in rust allows us
to convert a shared reference to an
exclusive reference otherwise it's
undefined behavior and so we say that a
thread band is always sync because we
synchronize on thread ID if they're not
the same then we don't give you a
reference so we use this in seek because
our read and write transactions are
naturally synchronous they're bound to a
thread already we don't want to have to
synchronize on them so the thread bound
just gives us a way to guarantee that
we're doing the right thing and if we so
because we're fairly confident that we
do the right thing and seek we also just
compile a check out in release builds
and so it just catches us in debug so in
getting a ROI we return a star mutti
from an exclusive or from a shared
borrow in rust that's important because
we need the exclusive borrow of the
underlying value to be disjoint from the
shared borrow that checks thread ID it's
a fairly subtle issue but if they
weren't disjoint then we would have a
shared reference that overlaps how
exclusive reference and that's undefined
behavior so that's kind of subtle
typically you don't need to build these
things though you can just use mutex so
there was one additional subtlety with
thread bound it gives us sync but it
doesn't give us sinned because we store
the value in loan if our value reaches
finalization we still need for that
underlying value to be safe to move into
that finalization thread so some types
just aren't like that they have some
thread local state so in comes deferred
cleanup which is like thread bound
weirdness plus plus it's additionally
odd it allows us to drop values that
aren't send without creating data races
it looks kind of similar to our thread
bounder has a thread ID but it doesn't
store the value inline it allocates it
in thread local storage so we require to
use to ecstatic because the underlying
value may live for the duration of that
thread so we don't store it in line so
it's always safe to send the deferred
cleanup which is itself a here
to another thread you know accessing
underlying value we check it in the
thread local storage which is only going
to be correct for the thread that it was
allocated on we're deferred cleanup
comes into its own is during cleanup so
when we drop lon
deferred cleanup if we did it through
disposing c-sharp in the happy path
we're on the correct thread we simply
move out of our thread local storage if
we're on a finalization thread then we
send a message to the original thread
saying that it's got some garbage to
clean up but it'll come back and deal
with later so we may end up having our
values living for a lot longer than they
otherwise would have
but projects like karate use a similar
strategy like this already it's better
than creating data racism better than
leaking data all together all right
so just to give you some examples of
some handles that we have we have like a
DB store this is an instance of our
database it's naturally Sam sink so we
can stick it in handle shared we have a
DB writer it is safe to send because it
hasn't a thread local state but it's not
safe to access concurrently so we stick
in a handle exclusive and it's bound to
a thread then we have something like a
reader
it has thread local state so we can't
send it to another thread and we can't
access it concurrently so we need to
stick it in an exclusive handle behind
the deferred cleanup so that's a whole
lot of code that we've just looked at
and a whole lot of concepts so let me
give you an example of I'll show you
those concepts at work through our
sample code base so we created a
document perform through our UI this
time we will go and read that document
back out and we'll see some of these
Pete and own pieces in action okay so
I've issued a request a get request so
the first thing that we do is we begin a
retranslation in our c-sharp api doing
that means calling a binding function
like we did before so this is what the
bindings look like we have this maybe
check function and what maybe check does
is it calls check on the DB result that
we looked at earlier for us and so we
have our DLL import we have our calling
convention we also specify exact
spelling because you know
that does some stuff for us so back over
on the rest side we're in our binding
code now what we're going to do is
allocate our reader handle and so in
this case remember our reader is not
safe to finalize on its own so we
allocated a deferred cleanup we're not
going to have a look at the new the
implementation of deferred cleanup new
goods really ugly and I don't want you
see it so we allocated every return okay
now we're going to use some new bits
from the dotnet core 3 SDK in order to
write our document back into the
response stream so what we do is we
start an array we're going to enumerate
all the documents in our database that
means calling a binding function so we
call our binding function and now we're
back over in rust what we do is we get a
reference to our reader handle we then
pull a document out and we read it into
the C char provide buffer which in this
case isn't out and so if we recall from
before it's OK for us to get a reference
those uninitialized bytes from the out
because we're going to read into them
without writing we're going to write
into them in that reading so we've
written our document so we return ok we
then return that we had some data so the
buffer wasn't too small and we're not
finished yet so we materialize some data
so in this case we have an eye memory
owner and we have a range of the data
that we wrote because data takes
ownership of the underlying buffer we
don't just give it a span we give it the
own memory we then write it as a value
so that means calling this writers write
the string as a key all right the key as
a string and write the value as a
property so this is part of the new
system text JSON stuff so now we're
going to try and read the next document
so we call our binding function we get a
reference to our reader there are no
documents we only created one so we say
that we're done
so we end the array we've finished our
for each loop and now we dispose our
read transaction because we're finished
with it so we call another binding
function and we complete the reader and
now we're going to drop out of fare
cleanup because we did the right thing
we're on the right thread we call
dispose and then we just move out of the
in a value we don't need to create any
garbage on the queue and there's that
document that we wrote earlier in the
session okay so we've looked at what a
hybrid app is why you might want to
write one we've had a look at rust and
we've had a look at c-sharp and some
features of the dotnet runtime so what
might be coming up next for hybrid apps
in the future you might think that's
something like wisdom as the
technologies allows you to take your
favorite language in more places might
give you no real need to create hybrid
apps so you can just take c-sharp
everywhere and if that's aweso you
if that's what floats your boat then
that's awesome
it also gives us an opportunity to
create more hybrid apps we can share
components between c-sharp no JavaScript
runtime like if you have a query
language for instance that you want to
share an implementational you could do
that
similarly shared compiled platforms like
LLVM make it possible for us to stitch
languages together more tightly than
ever before so those demos that I was
showing you before where we could step
through c-sharp and rust in a single
debug session where possible because we
were using karate to compile our c-sharp
ahead of time statically linking in our
rust library and so they're effectively
one binary and so we debugging then
using ll DB rather than the core CLR
debugger so that's that's pretty well
yep I hope you got something out of that
that was a pretty whirlwind tour of rust
so please come and find me we'll reach
out on Twitter or anywhere if you have
any questions and thank you all very
much
[Applause]